being recognized in public is still like
something I find really difficult
because I'm just not that way in clients
to I'm not that outgoing so I still find
it difficult so that is something uh
we've had to move because people have
found like where we live then there's
people that would like Drive their kids
hundreds of miles because to my front
door and
post things through my letterbox the
sell fireworks outside my house that
kind of crazy stuff that you just never
thought would you'd ever have to deal
with
[Music]
inspired you to get into YouTube
I was really into Pokemon cards but I
used to instead of collecting them I
actually played the game like not many
people knew how to play the game
um so I actually played it went to
tournaments all that kind of stuff I was
able to
[Music]
get a sponsor to like fund the travel
buying the cards
and that's where I made my Pokemon Dan
level 45 Channel which is the one before
the one that I uh is my main Channel now
the main channel was like almost 10
years old so this one's been like 12 or
13 years ago
hi over you
I'm 30 now so like 16 yeah 16 17 years
old
and then Minecraft came along so my
brother showed me Minecraft I absolutely
loved it went and downloaded it the same
day after he showed me on console and I
probably played it every day since
and then I watched to learn how to play
Minecraft I watched it on YouTube so
people like
would show you how to survive your first
night or build certain houses and then
since then I haven't looked back 10
years later and I'm still still making
Minecraft videos
were your parents not supportive and
like were your friends supportive did
they don't have your friends at school
when you were 16 know that you were
making Pokemon videos no no I didn't
tell anyone I was faceless on the um the
Pokemon Channel
and on the Minecraft one actually for a
while
so I didn't tell anyone about it I would
ask people about Minecraft and Pokemon
but normally they wouldn't be into it so
I just won't mention it then I was
pretty shy as a kids
um not really shy actually by the time I
got to like secondary school if you talk
to me I just glow red and she's like
yeah please don't talk to me because I
just I just painfully shy
how does someone who's shy get into
essentially making YouTube videos just
slightly performing
that's a good question
um I think it's easier because you're in
the room by yourself
you're not already performing to anyone
like I didn't live stream back then but
even live streaming you're still
performing in front of no one
that you can see if that makes sense
like if I got up in front of
10 or 20 people to do a a presentation
at Uni I would I'd hate it like I'd
really hate that but at the same time I
was doing YouTube videos that would get
tens of thousands of views it's just not
the same when they're not directly in
front of you and then when did it go
from being okay this is a hobby I do to
being I can actually make this a job
it transitioned when my first video
really popped off and it was like really
getting popular I started uploading it
every single day I was doing uni I was
doing a part-time job in there but still
making sure I uploaded every day and I
got a uh my first pay when I joined an
MCN and it was like two thousand dollars
or something I was like this is way more
than I own at Tesco's I mean it was in
my kitchen I opened the email and I was
like I was so excited I wish I could
have that feeling again it was just like
the pure euphoria that I could make
money off of video games and videos
I quit Tesco which is where I was
working at the time still went to Union
finished that so I was almost finished
and then again from there I just never
looked back still doing it to this day
and like one video a day and I've read
that you did two videos I did yeah for a
long for how long were you doing two
videos a day for
two or three years like it was not an
exhausting yeah so I didn't do anything
so I literally would go to UNI that was
when when I finished uni that summer is
when it really popped off and that's
when I started doing the two videos a
day
uh I came up with the ideas I
thumbnail'd I edited I rendered them I
did everything for years I only started
using editors probably about three or
four years ago
so I did everything and because I
enjoyed it so much I wanted I knew I
wanted the end product to be like the
video
did you ever feel like you're burning
out from doing all that eventually I
burn out yeah I think the good thing
about when I was doing two videos a day
is you'd go to sleep wake up and there'd
be so many new things in Minecraft so
you have
access to a lot of content you can use
to make videos Minecraft's really unique
as it's like more popular now than it
has ever been I think but it's always
gone in like that wave kind of up and
down Peaks and troughs
um
I think with Minecraft specifically it's
just someone comes out with a new way to
play the game or a new way to make a
video like smps are really popular now
which is servers but then back when I
started doing it it was storytelling mod
showcases stuff like that so it's all
about following Trends and Minecraft's
had a lot of them but still trying to
find two things every single day 365
days a year to make videos on eventually
got really difficult yeah but by the
time you brought other people in to
start helping with videos what level of
subscribers were you at oh God uh
probably like
15 million or something yeah
and then we gotta talk about like
obviously you've been phenomenally
successful in this area you're the
single most subscribed to person on in
the UK yeah 20 over 26 million
subscribers
I think there is a couple higher but
yeah how is that success impacted you
oh in all kinds of ways like
in terms of
just being someone I guess the biggest
impact would be
that I was someone that's so shy and
then having that kind of attention on me
I just didn't like it being recognized
in public is still like something I find
really difficult because I'm just not
that way inclined to I'm not that
outgoing so I still find it difficult so
that is something uh we've had to move
because people have found like where we
live then there's people that would like
Drive their kids hundreds of miles
because to my front door and post things
through my letterbox sell fireworks
outside my house that kind of crazy
stuff that you just never thought would
you'd ever have to deal with and you
come from a place that's not like media
trained you have no one
in your family that's gone through that
before normally you're just under
someone in a bedroom who made video game
videos
and it's a whole lot to learn really
quickly
you said that being shy how does it feel
then when you see a sea of people
oh they're one thing your attention it's
weird I've been thinking about that a
lot recently it's like imposter syndrome
you're like is that really like me like
if I watch something when I've been
doing my tours or something like Legends
of gaming I um is that really meaning am
I really doing that it is almost like
there's two people there's there's
normal regular you just lives day to day
and then there's like the Performing
side of you but they're the same person
it's really a strange feeling I remember
I think the first venue we did was about
two to three thousand people so we'd
even play games uh just in front of an
audience they can kind of see like the
YouTube experience live and we'd only
ever practiced it in front of like 10
because you just can't practice in front
of that many people just slowly build it
up you're like you've got it in your
head you know what the show is meant to
be you know what you're supposed to do
and I'll do it and I remember one of the
producers of this show said to me that
before I came up on the stage my first
show they were like I hope you can do
this because there was just there was no
evidence that I could
but when you get up there in front of
those people doing something you love it
and enjoy
here's this just like this Rush that you
get that's not you can't really get it
anywhere else it's so you such unique of
an experience it's
it's so much fun some of the people that
works on Legends of the game and
approached me with the idea of doing it
as a tour so taking the characters
basically doing the same thing but kind
of taking it out of Minecraft because on
the stage show we had big screen behind
me all my characters were there I'd talk
backwards and forwards with them and
yeah that's how it was born really uh
just wanting the challenge of
making a video live I guess and taking
those characters just to the next level
we started with four days we did four
days something with Brian I can't
remember where else we did it and then
because it was so popular it was kept
going and going and going and going like
almost two years later we're done
the whole of America Australia twice the
UK
pretty much everywhere yeah you saw the
Sydney Opera house tonight you're in the
Sydney Opera House yeah four times
just four times yeah yeah you played
four shows of it that was probably one
of my favorites like that is such an
iconic venue yeah I've used asked
someone to name most iconic live venues
in the world that's gotta be in
someone's top three every time it's like
it's iconic yeah yeah so do you think a
lot of the YouTubers if you're a kind of
generation
are introverts who were in their
bedrooms as kid making videos and then
all of a sudden they've thrown into up
into these big things yeah I'd say the
majority are or yeah especially like my
generation where it wasn't you couldn't
aspire to be a YouTuber because it
wasn't a thing so yeah I think a lot of
us were people who wanted to show
the world are like real personalities
but just didn't have the confidence to
do it in real life so we used a camera
in video games and combined that instead
and I uploaded it instead which is it's
kind of mad to think about really
so obviously your content is child
friendly yeah it's mainly it's your
audience is mainly children or teenagers
growing by
what it was not a conscious decision
from the start
uh no my old videos are full of swearing
there's still so there's literally
swearing compilations with me on YouTube
which is funny to look at now but I
think everyone has that like other
YouTubers that then turn really family
friendly so I did make that conscious
decision to cut out swearing and also be
careful about what was in my videos like
any blood I wouldn't play the game any
like extreme violence I wouldn't play
the game
um it's different now because everyone's
grown up so I'm a little less conscious
about that
my main channel is still and will always
be
family friendly I wouldn't say it's kids
orientated because
the kid orientated stuff now is like
really fast paced in your face shouting
over excited I'm just not I'm not about
that anymore I'm 30 years old I can't
keep up with that it gives me a headache
but um I do have another Channel where I
made it
apparent and I'd made it very clear that
that stuff would be there'd be gains of
blood in it there'd be gains of swearing
in it I even made a separate Twitter
account so those things you know what
you get from each platform so my main
Twitter account my main Channel you know
is going to be pretty much safe whereas
the alt accounts I do what I want and
that is the rules are kind of made very
clear you've opened up in the past of
your mental health okay
can you can you tell us a little bit
about the Ohio so what was a distinctive
career you're in impacted your mental
health
definitely
um I think because you spend a lot of
time alone and in that just that YouTube
grind if YouTube isn't going well it
drastically affects your mental health
because we do something where
you could
become irrelevant which isn't as
important but you kind of like lose
what you enjoy so much there's always
that fear that it could just tomorrow to
disappear so when things aren't going so
well
there's
the massive mental battle we have to do
to
not let affect you too much and just
remember that you're literally you're
playing video games for a living this is
still really cool you still get to do
something really unique even if it's not
going your way at the minute eventually
everything will be all right yeah do you
still feel that fear that it could all
go away even though you're 26 million
yeah I think I took about two months off
and came back and my video was a 10 out
of 10. it was which is bad in YouTube in
the dashboard so 10 out of 10 it means
it's your worst performing video out of
your last 10 and I was like oh this
sucks and I had to like build up the
momentum again but you have to catch
yourself before you get in that
um the numbers game with yourself like
comparing yourself to other people like
why are my videos not doing that well
it is a constant mental battle but you
have to just trying to try and catch
yourself before it gets that bad yeah I
think after my son was born I had uh
postnatal depression and that was really
difficult because
you need
you need to perform to an extent in a
YouTube video because you need to
be enjoying the game but when you're not
feeling that
at all like you're not feeling
you're just not feeling happy or
positive at all trying to do that is
really difficult like you're almost like
Faking It
and I don't want to do that for videos
it's just something I don't want to do I
don't want to ever fake a reaction or
fake being excited about something it's
just not something I want to do and
enjoy so that was a really really tough
point in my life to the young YouTubers
who are kind of up and coming now
um going to be like the next big thing
what would you say to them to look after
their Mental Health
don't try not to put everything into
try not to make it as important to
become a YouTuber becoming a YouTuber
now is so much harder than it used to be
and even for us to make it into a job
when it wasn't one it was still really
difficult
um
it's hard to not suggest to work really
hard and do that two video a day grind
because that's what I did but I wouldn't
recommend it
I was at the right time in my life when
I did it
um
I think always keep it as something you
enjoy as a hobby and then if eventually
it does turn into something you can make
money out of and and eventually turn
into a job or at least
um
make it so it means you don't have to
get a part-time job something like that
it doesn't have to be a super stardom
the whole way
it must be incredible to see how far
you've come even in that just in the
wealth sense I was like looking at going
like Yeah from Tesco to where you are
now yeah
I feel like I'm a pretty humble person
like I don't spend a lot of money so it
just like
it's just there it's like it's really
weird it's like I still do exactly what
I used to when I had a thousand
subscribers to now obviously I do like
the tours and stuff but the the core of
what I do is making videos which is
stayed the same
um so it is weird to have
yeah it's weird for it to be there yeah
with mainstream media in particular
older they're weird there's this
Obsession around yeah how much money you
should return I think the media or like
old school media was more obsessed when
it started to become a job because
we were not only doing it as like a
full-time job we were like exceeding
that and then
earning a lot of money
um as a one-man team compared to what a
traditional Media company has which is
hundreds and thousands of employees
I thought it was weird at the time but I
guess it was just interesting to them
like it was it was usually depicted in a
negative like like why are they just
playing video games again paid Millions
but there was a lot more to it than that
and I think
because we could talk to our audience
more directly we
they got that our audience know that
that there's more to it than that so it
didn't really matter too much it was
more the
I knew how much I was earning but then
for it to be on such a public
um
like a big company like Forbes like a
really trusted Financial
reporter that now everyone in the world
and your family knows the in like how
much
like a ballpark of how much you make is
that was challenging too actually yeah
how was that challenging because family
members would suddenly pop up
and then be like oh
it just becomes
it's always been taboo to ask like
someone how much they earn because no
one needs to know but when it's
I mean they guessed but they got it
pretty accurate
that now everyone knows your financial
situation it's just it's just really
strange
and then on a happier I want to talk
like because obviously you know you're
you're 30 you're one of the which is
strange thing to say you're one of the
Elder students yeah YouTube yeah um
you've got this Minecraft and another
boom as you said you've got these young
Minecraft youtubers coming up like Tommy
in it and dream and people like that
like how how has that been seeing
another generation come through after
you
it's been really interesting because
I talked to Tommy quite a bit and he
literally watched my videos when he was
growing up and now he is doing the same
thing on a much larger scale as well
it's just like
I think that's partly because there's so
many more people are watching YouTube
and consuming twitch and stuff so if you
do blow up and go viral it's so much
bigger than it was nine years ago
especially with them being so young it's
easy for someone to like swoop in and
take them down the wrong path and then
end up I mean it's usually money related
where someone will take advantage of a
YouTuber who maybe doesn't know how to
read a contract properly or anything
like that
and I feel like I've made some of those
mistakes so I can help someone that is
new to the space not make those mistakes
it's almost like a it is almost like a
father like protecting thing like you're
so young I can help you to avoid these
situations or help to keep your your
mental health in check just a little bit
um I'm all for helping as as many of
them as I can with anything
is there anyone you're looking at and
you go they've got something
over summer I've always got my eye out
because usually over summer some
holidays when kids are off school
someone blows up like it just happens
there's always one YouTuber that goes
from
the small times are massive it always
happens so I'm looking forward to seeing
who that is next and then you mentioned
thumbnails there and like I think
it's an interesting people don't realize
how much work goes into a thumbnail yeah
especially nowadays yeah but then what
do you makes a good thumbnail
so I make all my thumbnails so in
Photoshop you've got 100
I always take mine down to 12.5 because
that's how people view it on a phone
in the recommended your thumbnail is
never a 1080p ever it's always really
small so if your thumbnail works
and gets the message across that you
want it to at that size then you've done
a good job I mean I'm always trying to
make them better but simpler is always
better
like how where do you see it going how
where do you think things will go in the
future
it'd be interesting to see when I reach
like 40 50 that kind of generation where
what new comes in because I can't really
think apart from like VR that hasn't
really been tapped into
I don't know what else there is to do
like streaming boards then you've got
the short form videos like kind of
already there already and as we were
growing up technology just had this
massive boom anyway and now it's kind of
stalled out so I honestly have no idea
do you think there's a point where
you'll stop
making YouTube videos
uh I mean I didn't think I'd be doing it
for like 10 years so I don't know when I
would stop I have to create like no
matter what it is where it's drawing
music videos I have to just be creating
something otherwise I go crazy
so I like to think I'll just do it for
as long as people are interested maybe
even longer I'll just make them because
I love making videos
I'm I'm slowed down but I'm not stopping
yet
I think when I had about six half a
million I had a call with KSI and he was
like so wonderful to me you know and
being like one of the most intimidating
guys in YouTube and someone I've always
really really looked up to Mr Beast
Casey neistat would like all have been
really helpful and wonderful and I've
had calls with most of them for advice